mes collègues
cher monsieur desmed nous avons donc le
plaisir de vous accueillir ce matin vous
êtes professeur d'économie à
l'Université de Bourgogne et vous
intervenez régulièrement sur les
questions ayant très au crypto actifs
donc nous avons je vous l'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure avant une table ronde qui
débutera 10h30 et portera sur le double
enjeu d'innovation et de régulation des
crypto actifs mais il m'a semblé
nécessaire peut-être parce que comme je
vous l'ai indiqué
j'en ressentais le besoin à titre
personnel déjà que nous disposions
d'éléments de compréhension commun sur
ce que sont concrètement les crypto
actifs ainsi que sur la manière dont il
fonctionne c'est un monde tellement
mouvant que je n'arrive pas à suivre de
quoi on parle finalement au fond les
dernières auditions notre commission
consacrée spécifiquement à ce sujet date
de 2018 avec une première table ronde
qui avait été consacrée aux nouveaux
usages et à la régulation des chaînes de
blocs blockchain et une seconde
consacrée au risque et aux enjeux liés à
l'essor des monnaies virtuelles
depuis les usages liés aux crypto actifs
se sont multipliés sans que leur
fonctionnement ne soit nécessairement
bien compris en tout cas par mois je le
confirme par ailleurs la question des
crypto actifs surgit régulièrement lors
de nos auditions comme celle du
gouverneur de la Banque de France ou
plus récemment encore de la présidente
de l'autorité nationale des jeux c'est
donc sans plus attendre que je vous cède
la parole monsieur de se mettre pour que
vous puissiez éclairer notre commission
sur la définition la création et le
fonctionnement des actifs numériques au
sens large en vous rappelant que votre
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo
retransmises en direct sur le site du
Sénat je vous demanderai si c'est
possible de vous tenir dans à peu près
25 à 30 minutes de manière à permettre
un échange avec les collègues qui nous
ont rejoints pour cette préchauffage si
je puis dire qui nous paraît utile ce
matin
[Musique]
je vous salue mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs donc je vais essayer de vous
présenter les actifs numériques en ayant
un propos liminaire c'est que je ne suis
ni informaticien ni juriste ni acteur du
monde des crypto monnaie j'ai un intérêt
intellectuel disons pour cette cette
révolution en cours et j'aimerais
retracer un peu le contexte comme il
m'était demandé d'une histoire brève qui
a 15 ans le point de départ c'est 2008
mais extrêmement dense en trois parties
si vous n'aurez bien d'abord le contexte
d'apparition de la blockchain et de des
possibilités de finances décentralisée
ensuite la diffusion c'est à dire
l'effervescence qui qui sont les suivis
il y a une dizaine d'années et un état
des lieux actuel avant de répondre à vos
questions donc en premier lieu
l'apparition des systèmes décentralisés
bon sont directement liés à la crise de
la finance traditionnelle on a le on a
le choc la faillite de Lehman Brothers
le 15 septembre
2008 avec
une explosion de d'une finance qui était
devenue difficilement contrôlable des
réguler et on a une réaction immédiate
alors qui d'abord passe inaperçu 45
jours après la faille de la main
Brothers se paraît sur une petite liste
de diffusion un texte de 9 pages d'un
inconnu qui s'appelle enfin qui se qui
s'autoproclame satoshina Kamoto mais on
ne sait toujours pas qui qui il est donc
qui diffuse sur cette petite liste de
diffusion d'une dizaine de personnes un
White Paper un papier qui propose un
système qui dénonce à la fois la
connivence des banques et des états
comme ils le dis donc on est en pleine à
ce moment là on est quand même en phase
de quasiment pas frontières suite à la
faillite et Nakamoto donc expose un
programme informatique qui d'après lui
permettrait aux usagers de se passer à
la fois du contrôle des banques et des
états bon son papier en fait fait suite
à une dizaine d'années de travaux en
informatique dans un milieu qu'on
appelle un milieu cyberlibertarien qui
consistait à vouloir se passer justement
du contrôle étatique dans le domaine
bancaire et une des figures de ce milieu
qui est encore aujourd'hui très présente
médiatiquement c'est l'homme musk par
exemple qui était vraiment dans ce
milieu là en pensant que l'informatique
pourrait
permettre aux acteurs de se passer de du
contrôle et de la régulation donc
qu'est-ce que propose Nakamoto il
propose un système de chaîne de blocs
qui est désormais un peu connu la
blockchain qui est un système de assez
ingénieux de de validation
le but étant de se passer de ce qu'il
appelle un tiers de confiance c'est à
dire ce qu'on appelle une banque tout
simplement la banque étant l'acteur qui
dans le monde financier tient les
comptes on a une centralisation on
compte
depuis les Italiens qui ont inventé ce
système là on a un banquier qui fait
l'intermédiaire et qui vérifie l'état
des comptes ce que propose un Kamoto
donc c'est cent job box qui est une
espèce de système GPS
comment dire valider de manière autonome
par les acteurs sans centralisation
c'est à dire que la blockchain et ce
qu'il appelle un livre ouvert c'est à
dire que on a si on veut enregistrer une
transaction la transaction est proposée
à l'ensemble du réseau
avec des validateurs qui sont bénévoles
à l'époque et chaque transaction est
enchaînée dans une espèce de de bloc
numérique qui est validé par l'ensemble
des validateurs c'est à dire c'est le
réseau qui se qui s'auto régulent en
quelque sorte et donc on ne peut pas
modifier une fois qu'un bloc est validé
par le réseau on ne peut plus modifier
les informations qui sont dedans
elles sont heureux datées c'est un
système de redattage mais pour que le
système fonctionne il faut justement
qu'il y a des gens qui surveillent
bénévolement et c'est là qu'il invente
du même chef ce qu'il appelle le Bitcoin
de coin selon les espèces métalliques en
anglais le Beats ce sont les unités
informatiques et le Bitcoin et la
rémunération qui va permettre de
à un des validateurs bénévoles donc de
toucher une rémunération virtuelle
lorsqu'il aura résolu un défi numérique
donc on a un algorithme qui propose un
défi numérique on a des ordinateurs qui
se mettent en réseau et celui qui est le
plus rapide à valider la chaîne de bloc
gagne ses Bitcoin qui à l'origine ça
c'est important je pense ne va rien ce
sont des billets de Monopoly virtuels
c'est une espèce de jeu au début c'est
vraiment un prototype il faut vraiment
avoir
en tête l'idée que lorsque le premier
Bitcoin était mis en 2009 janvier 2009
il ne vaut rien c'est un prototype
DC de validation des transactions
monétaires de manière décentralisée donc
on a un algorithme qui propose des défis
et on a des validateurs qui essayent de
gagner ce Bitcoin qui est encore une
fois sans valeur bon alors au début ça
n'intéresse que les militants c'est à
dire ceux qui étaient dans le milieu
cyber libertariens ou crypto anarchiste
comme on dit aujourd'hui
donc quelques dizaines centaines de
personnes qui qui essayent de tester le
système et puis à un moment donné le
système qui est purement alternatif va
rentrer dans le monde réel c'est à dire
qu'on va commencer à avoir des échanges
de Bitcoin contre des monnaies réelles
dollars euro etc ça c'est à partir de
2010 mais le Bitcoin a une valeur
insignifiante même pas un centime c'est
à dire que voilà c'est une espèce de jeu
on teste un peu la résistance du système
et le fait que je ne l'ai pas signalé
mais le fait que chaque ordinateur qui
est en connexion avec le réseau soit
enregistré par une ligne de code c'est à
dire qu'il préserve l'anonymat en tout
cas chacun est enregistré par un
pseudonyme fait que ça va commencer à
intéresser des acteurs disons
peu recommandables qui vont pouvoir
avoir à disposition un moyen de
transfert de fond en dehors des radars
des banques et des états et donc tout ce
qui est trafic terrorisme etc est
intéressé par ce système alternatif
puisque ça permet de faire transiter des
fonds d'un bout à l'autre du réseau donc
d'un bout à l'autre de la planète sans
avoir à se soucier du contrôle
donc aux militant succèdent les on va
dire les mafia disons et le Bitcoin donc
prendre la valeur puisque c'est la
demande qui fait le prix l'offre est
purement automatisée c'est un algorithme
donc c'est la demande qui fait le prix
et donc de quelques centimes on passe à
une unité en dollars en euros et puis en
2011-2012 on commence à avoir un Bitcoin
qui est demandé il passe de 10 à 100
dollars et il continue à monter et à
partir de ce moment là deuxième effet du
choc Léman Brothers ce qui est
fondamental dans cette histoire c'est
que on est dans un monde de taux
d'intérêt nul et donc dans un monotone
intérêt nul lorsque vous avez une valeur
dont on ne sait pas ce que c'est qui n'a
aucune régulation juridique mais dont le
prix monte parce que la demande augmente
on a quelque chose qui a un rendement
positif dans un monde de taux d'intérêt
nul et donc se mettent à s'intéresser au
Bitcoin à partir de 2011-2012 tout un
tas d'investisseurs qui se disent ben
voilà on a quelque chose qui prend 10
cent
plus de 100% dans l'année c'est
intéressant et donc on a une
financièreisation du Bitcoin et donc
c'est la deuxième partie de mon
intervention c'est que un moment la
finance va rencontrer ce cet objet
totalement original et va y avoir une
exportation des potentialités de la
blockchain et c'est là qu'on commence à
parler des jetons des token en anglais
c'est à dire qu'on va voir une une
effervescence une prolifération de tout
un tas d'instruments difficil facilement
catégorisables en termes juridique mais
qui vont permettre à différents acteurs
de prendre possession de la blockchain
donc d'autres crypto monnaie déjà
puisque le Bitcoin est seul sur le
terrain mais à partir de 2011 2012 on
commence à voir des
etc une prolifération de crypto monnaie
certaines
greffons d'autres originalités comme les
terres l'été Rome qui permet de mettre
dans la chaîne de blog des document
attachés ce qu'on appelle des smart
contracts des contrats intelligences
c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez très bien
faire valider aussi un fichier texte qui
prévoit certaines modalités des contrats
vous pouvez insérer dans la blockchain
des contrats
c'est ce qu'on appelle les jetons
intelligents
des stables coin aussi qui est aussi une
nouveauté aux alentours de 2014
c'est à dire là on a des des jetons
numériques qui vont garantir une valeur
faciale
stable comme le teaser qui est la plus
connue qui vaut 1 dollar donc là l'idée
n'est pas d'acheter
contrairement à l'Ethereum ou le Bitcoin
pour revendre plus cher plus tard mais
c'est d'avoir une valeur stable
et donc une garantie contre les contre
les variations mais là on a un hôtel des
monnaies comme il est dit dans le dans
la fiche d'intention de tes heures c'est
à dire que il y a une régulation une
espèce de banque centrale qui qui va
réguler le cours forcément la quantité
donc il y a une prolifération pour
atteindre des sommets
il y a quelques années on avait plus de
10000 crypto monnaie et puis
on a l'innovation étant en marche depuis
2008-2009 on a aussi des opérations de
financement qui s'opèrent grâce aux
jetons c'est ce qu'on appelle les ICO
les introductions en Bourse disons en
actif numérique c'est à dire que
l'investisseur peut financer une
entreprise par exemple de jeux vidéo ou
autre en apportant des dollars ou des
euros et il reçoit un jeton qui lui
donne droit à utiliser les services de
cette entreprise une fois qu'elle sera
lancée donc ce ne sont ni des actions ni
les obligations ce sont des titres un
peu hybrides en jetons donc qui n'ont
encore une fois une existence légale
assez problématique mais qui satisfont
les deux parties l'investisseur qui qui
espère que l'entreprise lui permettra
d'accéder à ces services plus tard et
puis dernière innovation dans ces années
le marché de la Russie
la blockchain ce qui est important je
pense que dans la bonne chaîne c'est
qu'elle a introduit la singularité
l'unicité dans un monde duplication
infinie le numérique c'est le monde de
la duplication infinie c'est à dire
qu'on peut dupliquer les fichiers etc
etc
ce qui intéresse le monde de l'art c'est
qu'on a l'équivalent d'un tirage
numéroté
d'un tirage unique pour certains objets
numériques tels que des
des photos ou des choses comme ça qui
peuvent se vendre de même qu'on peut
acheter un tirage original de quartier
Bresson on peut acheter une oeuvre
originale créée sur un ordinateur et ce
sont les NFT les jetons non fongibles la
fongibilité étant le fait qu'on puisse
échanger toutes choses contre son image
un biais de 10 euros contre un autre
billet de 10 euros la non-fongibilité
c'est le fait que on a une unicité dans
ce monde numérique c'est à dire qu'on a
l'équivalent d'un tirage numéroté
et ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on peut
acheter des mètres carrés virtuels avec
des jetons non fongibles bon on rentre
dans un monde spéculaire à la physique
Cadic mais on a cette idée de
traçabilité de numérotation et de
singularité et de la vitesse et puis
puisque la machine est en marche on a
au-delà de cet effervescence
innovationnelle on a aussi de nouveaux
acteurs qui
rentrent dans ce monde numérique avec
d'abord au début les mineurs étaient des
bénévoles encore une fois ils recevait
quelque chose qui ne valait rien à
partir du moment où le Bitcoin vaut 100
euros 1000 euros 10000 euros etc à
partir de 2017 les mineurs deviennent
passent au stade industriel c'est-à-dire
là il y a un attrait réel le système de
validation conçu par Nakamoto était
purement idéal disons idéologique au
début là il y a des espèces sonnantes
éternueantes à gagner et donc on a des
mineurs qui deviennent des entreprises
avec des datacenters qui s'installent en
Islande au Canada etc et qui ont
énormément besoin de d'énergie d'énergie
peu cher puisque là plus le nombre
d'utilisateurs de de crypto monnaie est
important plus la masse de calcul
nécessaire pour valider les transactions
est important également à on considère
que pour valider une transaction en
crypto monnaie type Bitcoin il faut 1000
fois plus d'énergie que pour une
transaction visa c'est à dire que le
monde numérique est vraiment enchassé
dans le monde réel et à une dépense
énergétique considérable bon donc on a
ces fermes de minage
on a aussi alors que le projet de départ
était de se passer des banques on a des
banques qui s'installe qu'on appelle des
plateformes mais qui sont
fondamentalement on prend l'argent des
déposants en monnaie traditionnelle et
on le change puisque tout le monde n'a
pas les capacités informatiques de
participer aux jeux numériques on a
simplement des banquiers qui
s'installent qu'on appelle des
plateformes dont les plus connues
aujourd'hui sont by Nice ou coin base
avec les défauts d'un système très peu
régulier c'est à dire que on a des
fraudes des faillites
le président de la SEC il y a quelques
mois disait que le monde crypto
numérique c'était le Far West bon on a
le même phénomène que au 19e siècle aux
États-Unis c'est-à-dire que en 2014 on a
la faillite de la une des principales
plateformes à l'époque qui s'appelle une
des coqs qui fait faillite soi-disant
l'objet de fraude mais MT Cox recevait
des dépôts de clients et tu es censé
utiliser ces dépôts pour pour acheter
des crypto-monnaies et puis plus
récemment
l'intérêt des géants du numérique
forcément dans la dans la galaxie
numérique des firmes comme facebook
Spotify etc ont été très intéressés et
on a annoncé en 2019 qu'il voulait
eux-mêmes créer leurs crypto monnaie
privée sous le nom de Libra diem
partie de cet excès d'épargne a été
redirigé vers le monde crypto avec une
bulle médiatique qui s'en est suivie
aussi les déclarations des lones musk ou
d'influenceurs plus ou moins invisés et
donc on a eu une explosion de la masse
de crypto monnaie de jetons etc le
Bitcoin atteignant les 60 000 euros fin
2021 un poids des transactions au
comptant de 3000 milliards de dollars
bon ce qui peut paraître considérable
mais en fait qui qui représenterait à
peu près la masse monétaire de la Suisse
pour donner une idée voilà on a on a une
espèce de pays crypto monétaire qui
représenterait à peu près le poids de la
Suisse 3000 milliards de dollars fin
2021 et même des États qui font la
bascule vers le Bitcoin monnaie légal on
a deux exemples Salvador et la
Centrafrique la République
centrafricaine bon ce qui peut laisser
un peu songeur mais
sans avoir aucune aucun contrôle sur le
cours ni sur les quantités émises bon
alors troisième point où on en est
aujourd'hui entre finance centralisé
finance décentralisée alors premier
point déjà il y a eu un très fort
dégonflement de la bulle
avec un changement de contexte
toutes ces monnaies sont très sensibles
au contexte
la fin de l'argent abondant avec la
remontée des taux d'intérêt
redonne des occasions de placement
alternatif une augmentation du coût
diminuage avec les coûts de l'énergie
qui ont augmenté et l'inflation on
entend souvent dire que le Bitcoin etc
sont des remèdes contre l'inflation ou
des refuges contre l'inflation c'est
totalement faux si on prend le cours du
Bitcoin il y a un an et demi qui est à
60000 à peu près 60000 euros aujourd'hui
à 20 000 vous pouvez acheter une Tesla
avec un Bitcoin à un an et demi il faut
trois Bitcoin pour acheter une le même
modèle aujourd'hui donc il y a de
l'inflation c'est-à-dire que il y a une
dévalorisation
ce n'est constitue pas du tout un refuge
contre l'inflation
et en conséquence la bulle c'est
dégonfler on est passé à 1500 milliards
à peu près de de de masse monétaire pour
les transactions contents des crypto
monnaies ont disparu les
icéos les financements directs par
remise de jetons de certaines
entreprises novatrices
progresse bien moins vite que avant la
crise du covid on a on a aussi de ce
côté là on a moins de moins de
financement de ce côté là on a eu un
dégonflement de la bulle des jetons non
fongibles les NFC sont quand même moins
prisés alors il y a un petit redémarrage
ces jours-ci avec les entreprises du
luxe mais bon ça devient vraiment un
quelque chose de niche et une hausse de
la demande par contre pour les stable
coin c'est à dire les jetons soi-disant
à valeur à valeur fixe qui eux
sont pour la plupart adossés au dollars
et ce qu'on a aussi aujourd'hui c'est
une colonisation de la finance des sens
soit disant décentralisée par la finance
centralisée les intermédiaires
traditionnels colonisent dans quelque
sorte le monde de la défi de la finance
décentralisée avec des produits dérivés
qui ont donné lieu à l'explosion de
l'eman Brothers et on retrouve des
produits dérivés dans le monde des
crypto-monnaies aujourd'hui il y a plus
de transactions dérivés sur le Bitcoin
et les devises apparentées que de
transactions comptant on a aussi des
grands groupes bancaires type Morgan
Stanley ou Goldman Sachs ou en Allemagne
Deutsche Bank qui se lance dans des
services crypto pour capter une
clientèle souvent jeune
c'est beaucoup moins présent en France
par exemple
mais les crypto ont encore une fois été
contaminés par la finance traditionnelle
et désormais suive avec des excès les
soubresauts de des marchés financiers
et du coup on a reproduction de certains
phénomènes qui étaient dénoncés au début
par Nakamoto c'est-à-dire qu'on a une
extrême concentration en fait de ce
monde-là qui pourrait être on parle de
finance décentralisée mais en fait il y
a une très faible diversité c'est à dire
que on a les cinq principales crypto
monnaie concentre 70 80% des échanges
c'est la même centralisation pour les
plateformes on a 4 5 plateformes qui
concentrent l'échange des essentiels des
opérations de change
pareil pour les groupes nominage c'est à
dire qu'on est vraiment arrivé à un
stade de d'oligopole industriel des
plateformes des mineurs des monnaies
avec des phénomènes traditionnels qui
est le phénomènes de bulle financière à
un qu'on connaît depuis des siècles
depuis qu'on a des marchés financiers
modernes une bulle c'est quoi c'est une
innovation qui donne naissance à une
espérance de gain et cette espérance de
gain fait affluer des capitaux dans un
marché qui a du mal à les absorber les
mouvements de 2017 2021 montre bien bien
ça des phénomènes aussi qui sont très
anciens aussi des phénomènes de panique
panique bancaire des banques run c'est à
dire que on a des déposants qui
s'inquiètent pour l'avenir de leur dépôt
et qui viennent retirer les fonds
et on a eu ça il y a quelques mois avec
la faillite de la l'une des principales
plateformes de change FTX
FTX qui a connu un run une panique
financière qui a fait faillite alors
qu'elle était évalue à peu près à 30
milliards de dollars
et FTX qui avait une très grande
connexion avec les paradis fiscaux
puisque après avoir été installé à Hong
Kong elle s'est elle s'était relocalisée
au Bahamas donc on a une très grande
proximité aussi avec ce qu'on appelle le
shadow banking aujourd'hui qui est qui
est en expansion avec la banque ou la
finance non annulée c'est-à-dire que les
plateformes de change aime beaucoup les
paradis fiscaux
donc on a ce paradoxe d'un instrument
conçu comme une alternative au système
bancaire traditionnel et financier
traditionnelle qui devient une espèce de
de
refuge pour certaines pratiques
déluctuelles alors en conclusion si vous
voulez bien
quelques points la blockchain constitue
vraiment un tour de force
une innovation indéniable pour
transmettre des informations de manière
décentralisée c'est à dire que ce
système de blockchain n'a pas été mis en
défaut depuis 15 ans le fait que il y
ait une validation du réseau pour
transmettre des informations des
documents etc de manière rapide et
décentralisée c'est un succès bon par
contre son application à la monnaie est
un échec c'est à dire que lorsque
personne aujourd'hui n'utilise les
crypto les plus en vue pour les utiliser
dans le domaine des paiements ce sont
des instruments de spéculation c'est à
dire qu'on achète pour revendre plus
cher donc la finance a contaminé alors
que l'objectif était de fonder une
alternative et je ne pense pas que la
finance soit le meilleur terrain de
comment dire de
d'exercice pour pour la blockchain parce
que le tiers de confiance
se
dont vous voulez se débarrasser d'un
Kamoto
le tiers de confiance c'est à dire les
banques concentre les risques dans leur
bilan c'est un acteur qui prend en
charge les risques pour les autres en
quelque sorte et si vous dérégulez et si
vous laissez les usagers gérer eux-mêmes
les risques le risque disséminine
aujourd'hui l'OCDE vient de faire
paraître un rapport et on considère que
dans les pays du Nord les pays riches on
a peu près 10% des adultes qui
détiennent des crypto-monnaies
et donc cette diffusion des crypto
monnaie aussi diffuse du risque un
ensemble d'acteurs de plus en plus
importants
alors pour ce qui est de la régulation
il y a plusieurs options ensuite des
pays ont purement et simplement interdit
le minage la détention telle la Chine
qui a vraiment mis fin alors que la
Chine était le plus gros pays de minage
de de crypto monnaie l'ami fin
légalement assez à ces opérations on a
aussi le
l'exemple nord-américain aux États-Unis
lorsque Facebook a annoncé en 2019 qu'il
allait une crypto monnaie privée les
sénateurs américains ont reçu Mark
Zuckerberg en lui disant que facebook
allait changer de nature et que les
règles du jeu allaient changer et
Facebook a définitivement mis fin à son
projet enfin définitivement en tout cas
temporairement mifa à son projet de
crypto monnaie privée l'année dernière
donc il y a des moyens de régulation et
dans mes travaux je m'intéresse plutôt à
l'histoire longue de la finance on a il
me semble on a à peu près le même genre
de phénomène
à chaque période d'innovation si on
reprend la bancarisation en France
après la Première Guerre mondiale entre
deux guerres on a au niveau
réglementaire on a quasiment
une nation avec des lois très lâches
l'activité bancaire est très peu
réglementée au début du 20e siècle et on
a des scandales c'est à dire que les
usagers commencent à s'intéresser à la
bourse au papillonner qui est une
nouveauté et on a des scandales scandale
ou stries canaux Stavisky etc avec des
des tensions politiques qui en résultent
c'est-à-dire que le le
l'absence de régulation peut provoquer
lorsqu'elle touche des créneaux de
population important peut provoquer
quand même des des remous des scandales
etc et donc il faut attendre c'est
scandale pour avoir les premières
régulations bancaires à la fin des
années 30 en France il me semble que
pour augmenter le bien-être collectif de
la régulation dans ce domaine lorsque
les usagers sont de plus en plus
nombreux et dépassent largement le monde
des initiés comme c'était le cas au
début ça me semble quand même important
la monnaie la finance sont des
institutions sociales et donc on a
affaire à des questions certes et
techniques avec un vocabulaire parfois
ésotérique mais ce sont aussi des
questions politiques et je ne pense pas
que le laisser faire total soit une
bonne une bonne alternative dans ce
domaine je vous remercie pour votre
attention et
je peux répondre j'essaierai de répondre
à vos questions si vous en avez
merci Monsieur professeur bon et bien
écoutez en ce qui me concerne j'ai pas
tout à fait tout compris il faudra que
j'y revienne mais je ne sais quand même
beaucoup plus donc vous avez fait un
effort non non mais un effort de
synthèse et très pédagogique pour un
prof c'est quand même assez logique
enfin donc enfin le souhaite toujours
et donc on voit bien les glissements les
différentes époques parce que à chaque
époque finalement il y a un nouveau mot
qui apparaît un nouveau nom une nouvelle
fonction c'est ça que qu'on voit pas
premier abord et donc tous ces fonctions
vous les avez bien détaillées est très
clairement il y a des choses qu'on
achète et qui peuvent avoir une valeur
finalement c'est à dire une création
artistique après tout même numérique
pourquoi pas c'est une valeur alors de
la valeur que l'on veut mais il y a un
marché on comprend et puis il y a des
choses qu'on comprend moins c'est et ça
devient de la spéculation pure en
réalité c'est très bon alors si j'ai
compris c'est déjà enfin pour partie les
choses c'est déjà mieux
donc monsieur le rapporteur général
d'abord oui merci monsieur le Président
merci
au professeur desmettes je pense que
la présentation en tous les cas elle le
fait de comme vous l'avez dit dans la
partie finale de votre présentation le
fait de resituer dans l'histoire et
partirment intéressant moi je voudrais
revenir juste sur deux questions la
première vous avez et à mon avis à très
juste titre posé X fois et notamment
dans vos derniers propos la question de
la régulation donc c'est aujourd'hui
on voit bien que les banques centrales
ont vu ça de loin au départ
ça s'intéresse de beaucoup plus près et
s'inquiète du dispositif parce que dans
un monde où il y a pas de régulation
ça peut enfin comment diriger il peut y
avoir plus que de déviances ou de la
spéculation ça peut entraîner beaucoup
plus que ça donc
quel regard vous portez aujourd'hui sur
l'état des réflexions des banques
centrales et
je dirais non pas relativement mais vous
avez évoqué le rôle effectivement du
système bancaire dont vous dites c'est
le tiers de confiance pour les usagers
ce que vous regarde de la pratique
j'aurais tendance à voir ça un peu comme
au moment de l'apparition des fintech
ou le système bancaire regardez ça de
loin et puis après c'est intéressé et
puis souvent un certain nombre de
fintech on finit par être absorbés par
les grands groupes bancaires ce qui est
assez courant pas tous donc
si si il y avait comment dirais-je une
vision un peu prospective est-ce que
qui pourrait je dis pas gagner mais
comment pour évoluer les choses avec ce
secteur bancaire
aujourd'hui au regard de des crypto
actifs je pense que c'est plus complexe
mais est-ce que vous avez
à défaut de dire un pronostic une vision
un peu prospective merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur Roger
carochi puis Patrice jolie
merci professeur alors je ne vous cache
pas que j'ai pas tout compris non plus
et en tout cas j'ai compris que il y
avait des pays qui effectivement sont
des pays références pour aller vers le
Bitcoin le Salvador et Centrafrique peut
pas dire que ce soit au niveau
international les pays qui compte
vraiment sur le système financier si je
comprends bien je vous rassure je n'ai
pas investi en Bitcoin j'aurais pas
compris
ça ça m'aurait pas mais si je comprends
bien en fait c'est un instrument
purement spéculatif
fondé sur rien
ne créant rien
n'apportant rien
et qui au final ne maîtrisait par
personne puisque je vois que la valeur
est passée de 80000 euros à 22000 euros
en un an c'est à dire on a un peu le
sentiment que parce qu'on pourrait dire
mais il y a d'autres systèmes
spéculatifs mais les banques les
systèmes spéculatifs ont créé au fur et
à mesure du temps des moyens de
contraintes de contrôle avec des freins
notamment pour la chute comme pour
éventuellement une surévaluation là il y
a rien on a le sentiment que
aujourd'hui c'est 22000 dans six mois ça
peut être 5000 dans trois ans ça peut
être 100 000 mais fondé toujours sur
aucune réalité financière structurelle
etc et pardon pour le rapporteur général
mais quand il dit les grandes banques
les grandes entreprises s'y intéressent
comme pour la fintech mais pour les fin
de tête il y a quand même plus de
réalité derrière que pour ça donc ce que
je ne comprends toujours pas pardon
d'être un peu profane à la matière c'est
au-delà de du côté bon peut-être pour
les jeunes peut-être maintenant les
grands groupes qui veulent s'y
intéresser mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière en fait en vrai parce que on a
quand même le sentiment clair que c'est
une illusion d'optique qui plaît ou qui
plaît pas mais qui en tout cas n'a pas
de réalité ni matérielle ni financière
ni structurel à terme en quoi ce que
c'est un apport à l'économie mondial je
vois pas très bien
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
votre intervention du professeur très
éclairante j'aurais une question à poser
c'est que aujourd'hui vous l'avez évoqué
certains pays c'est de encadrer en tout
cas de construire des alternatives de
proposer d'internative assez crypto
monnaie je pense notamment à l'idée du
ruelle numérique de l'euro numérique et
en perspective j'ai pas bien compris la
différence en fait j'ai l'impression
qu'on a à faire quand même à une
différence de nature et j'aimerais que
vous puissiez m'apporter des précisions
à ce sujet et vous êtes passé assez
rapidement sur le scandale en tout cas
la des confitures de FTX peut-être nous
nous dire exactement ce qui a conduit à
cette déconfigurre et cette liquidation
merci
merci Patrice Sébastien me rend puis
Éric Bocquet merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Professeur
est-ce qu'on peut parler du
l'application à la finance comme d'un
échec comme des pays
choisissent ce système de financier même
si c'est le Salvador ou le Centrafrique
c'est il y a toujours un premier et puis
il y en a qui suivent
est-ce que sur les questions finalement
des monnaies numériques souveraines
vraiment ça c'est des sujets qui à mon
avis sont en réflexion et méritent de
d'y réfléchir le Libra de facebook
effectivement ils ont abandonné sous les
pressions du gouvernement américain mais
il y a d'autres d'autres grands groupes
qui étaient intéressés par la propre
création de de leur monnaie privée et
effectivement la question qui se pose
c'est la question de la régulation dans
des ensembles comme l'Union européenne
car comme disait Roger une monnaie peut
disparaître une monnaie peut avoir 50%
d'inflation donc la valeur 120 50% en un
an et dans certains pays dans le monde
actuellement il y a beaucoup de monnaies
où il y a de l'inflation donc quand les
acteurs privés peuvent acheter sur les
marchés où c'est la loi de l'offre et la
demande qui qui joue et bien une monnaie
virtuelle qui est une réserve de valeur
une raison de valeur qui repousse
effectivement sur les sur la blockchain
donc en tout cas c'est passionnant ça
mon compte venir et la France et la
votre avis sur le système économique
français on a quelques rares acteurs
mais on a nous étions avec la entreprise
il y a 15 jours chez Ledger qui est une
des rares licornes françaises donc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de de la place
de l'écosystème crypto français dans le
paysage européen et mondial merci
merci Sébastien Rick Bocquet puis Hervé
Mouret oui merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur Desmettre donc pour votre
présentation je suis un peu moins
ignorant moi-même ce matin après vous
avoir entendu quelques questions
complémentaires cependant et vous dites
que le réseau de crypto monnaie s'auto
régulent je suis toujours un peu
sceptique par rapport à cette histoire
là c'est un réseau de particuliers c'est
son ce sont des institutions qui est-ce
qui sont ces agents des réseaux en
question concrètement physiquement
deuxième point il y a quand même un
petit paradoxe vous dites vous avez fait
le lien avec la crise financière de 2008
qui a sanctionné quelque part les excès
d'une finance dérégulée complètement je
crois or ce système prétend être une
réponse à cette crise là et propose un
système encore moins régulier encore
plus anonyme encore plus complexe et ce
qui est un paradoxe ou est-ce que j'ai
mal compris la situation après vous
parlez d'investisseurs qui commencent à
s'intéresser à ce système parce que
forcément quand il y a de l'argent à
faire ça intéresse d'investisseurs mais
qui sont
ces investisseurs des particuliers
entreprises et institutions bancaires
etc
est-ce que la résa fédérale américaine
parce que c'est essentiellement c'est né
aux États-Unis cette affaire Silicon
Valley enfin essentiellement j'imagine
est-ce que la résa Federer américain a
une doctrine par rapport à cela on a
évoqué Facebook qui a renoncé à son
projet de création de monnaie Libra Diem
effectivement est-ce que c'est perçu
comme un
challenger politique éventuel parce que
on vous avait quand même parler de de
cyber libertariens de crypto anarchistes
est-ce qu'il y a un projet politique
derrière tout cela sans tomber dans le
controtisme enfin je ne crois pas trop à
des créations éthérées comme ça hors sol
voilà ça m'interpelle beaucoup alors
après vous dites et vous conclure en
disant le laisser faire total n'est pas
une option ce que je partage
complètement mais que ça veut dire
laisser faire total et quel type de
régulation pourrait-on imaginer on a
évoqué la chute de FTX est-ce que des
leçons ont été tirées ou est-ce que le
système considère que c'est ainsi que ça
va il y en a qui disp araissent il y en
a qui naissent et voilà et peu importe
quoi mais ça pose des questions en
termes de régulation et de souveraineté
d'un État notamment merci merci
Eric je vais demander
de respecter plutôt les deux minutes
déjà voyez on va essayer de faire une
première régulation entre nous
Hervé Moret puis Michel Canevet
merci monsieur le Président et merci à
vous d'avoir organisé cette audition
parce que je crois que c'est important
évidemment que notre Commission soit
mieux informée qu'elle ne l'est sur ce
phénomène que constitue les crypto
actifs de question que le professeur la
première vous avez peut-être vu ça notre
notre Assemblée a été à l'initiative
d'une amélioration de la régulation des
acteurs du crypto actif avec des
dispositions qui ont été adoptées
définitivement par le Parlement et qui
vise à améliorer le contrôle des
entrants malheureusement on n'a pas pu
faire évoluer les règles sur les acteurs
qui sont déjà sur le marché est-ce qu'à
votre avis il y a aujourd'hui un risque
par rapport aux acteurs qui sont le
marché qui sont sur le marché français
autrement dit est-ce que FTX à la
française est aujourd'hui envisageable
et deuxième deuxième question peut-être
encore plus difficile en terme de
réponse à apporter comment comment
carton si ce n'est par la spéculation
évidemment mais mais ces mouvements
absolument très importants de hausse
puis de baisse puisque l'année dernière
vous les rappeler on était à un niveau
que personne n'avait imaginé tellement
ça avait augmenté ensuite ça s'est
effondré on sait pas ce que ce sera
demain comment comment on peut expliquer
ça merci Hervé Michel canvé puis
Christian BIAC merci professeur de cette
présentation très pédagogique que vous
avez effectué ma question rejoint celle
que Sébastien me rend a posé tout à
l'heure puisque avec lui-même et Vincent
Seguin nous visitons Ledger à Vierzon il
y a quelques jours qui apparemment est
une licorne et donc est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'acteurs donc dans la sécurité
des crypto actifs est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'acteurs donc français qui
sont impliqués dans ce domaine qu'est-ce
que ça représente en termes d'entreprise
et d'emploi si vous avez un avis
Michel Christian BIAC puis Gérard
Longuet
merci président
qui nous a un peu éclairé sur ces crypto
actifs parce que c'est vrai que nous
avons nous sommes un peu moins ignorants
après cette exposé moi je
m'interroge sur l'utilité de ce crypto
actif effectivement font des choses rien
qui apporte rien sinon de l'opacité dans
les transactions financières
j'ai retenu quand même
quand aujourd'hui on enquêtine les gens
qui ont une vieille Clio pas si pollu de
l'énorme consommation énergétique de ces
de ces transactions mille fois vous
l'avez dit par rapport à une carte Visa
et donc quand on a la sauvegarde de la
planète et du climat
faudrait peut-être se pencher sur ce
volet énergétique des crypto monnaie qui
pour le plus que les agores fois que les
vieilles Clio et puis mode de question
la position de l'Europe est une position
de l'Europe
définie au niveau de cette échographie
et deuxièmement
stupide pardonnez-moi vous avez voté
1500 milliards de francs actuellement
c'est ça à peu près
qu'est-ce que ça représente pourcentage
par rapport
au fond des bacs centrales
Gérard Longuet puis Sophie Sylvie
vermeiller pardon bien merci cher
président de pour cette audition et
merci cher professeur pour ces cet
éclairage moi je voudrais poser la
question suivante quel est l'économie du
minage et du mineur vous avez évoqué
l'augmentation de du prix de l'énergie
c'était il est évident que pour gérer
les milliards de de d'informations ça
consomme une énergie absolument
considérable et au fond ce qui donne de
la valeur aux crypto monnaie c'est la
certitude de la rareté mais cette
certitude repose sur la multiplication
à l'infini des mineurs qui avec leur
petite leur petite pioche là sont en
train de creuser leur galerie pour pour
enfermer en quelque sorte la transaction
qui qui a vocation
à bénéficier de ce que l'on appelle un
tiers de confiance c'est-à-dire la
certitude de ne pas être dupliqué vous
avez évoqué c'était une très belle image
les dessins numérotés des preuves
d'artistes alors mais tout ça repose sur
des gens qui font cette profession qui
au début l'ont fait par je et par
intérêt intellectuel c'est devenu un
métier avec un investissement et qui dit
investissement dit recettes
amortissements économie du mineur
économie du minage je sais pas quelle
est la formule la plus exacte sur le
plan sémantique
merci
Gérard Sylvie vermeiller et Thierry
Cozic conclura les questions
monsieur le Président et Merci à VOUS
professeur pour cette présentation je
voudrais aborder la question de la
fraude à travers ses crypto vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure
brièvement les NFC non fongibles token
qui semble être particulièrement propice
pour la fraude à la TVA notamment la
fraude type carrousel
c'est NFC permettent d'être donc acquis
et céder instantanément entre par
exemple deux assujettis TVA au sein de
l'Union européenne et comme inexiste pas
de de flux physique la fraude est quand
même assez tentante n'existe pas non
plus de registre officiel qui permet de
faire le lien entre l'identité numérique
et l'adresse publique qui détient le
l'actif numérique
donc on voit tout de suite la faille
dans le système est-ce qu'il vous semble
logique et opportun qu'on puisse un
moment donné obliger les entreprises à
déclarer leur compte d'actifs numériques
à l'administration fiscale
merci Sylvie Thierry Cosic merci
monsieur le Président Merci à VOUS
professeur pour cette exposé
et surtout la compréhension de sujets
complexe moi j'aurais attirer votre
attention enfin vous interrogez sur la
protection des consommateurs vous avez
fait état de la trade des crypto actifs
qui aujourd'hui associé à une absence de
réglementation qui crée des risques
importants et notamment pour les pour
les consommateurs d'après des une étude
de Lipsos on considère qui a 8% des
Français qui auraient déjà investi dans
les dans ces crypto monnaie
l'écosystème de ces crypto actifs et
mouvants et plus encadré et vous l'avez
montré les multiples fraude et
manipulations du marché aurait
représenté 14 milliards de dollars en
on peut donc voir que c'est fraude et
ses risques financiers sont encouragés
par l'absence de contrôle encadrant le
secteur accentuer ainsi une forme
d'insécurité pour les consommateurs et
de votre point de vue comment on
pourrait protéger des consommateurs
contre les risques et associés à
l'investissement dans ces crypto actifs
et les aider à éviter les systèmes
frauduleux
bien merci professeur donc je vais vous
donner 15 minutes
ce qui compte tenu des questions posées
méritent attention si je puis dire
en sachant que un certain nombre de
questions reviendront pro c'est non pas
été traités et si le professeur n'a pas
eu le temps
d'y répondre pour en revenir dans le
débat qui suit tout à l'heure notamment
sur les questions liées à la régulation
puisque ce sera l'objet de la table
ronde suivante ce professeur sur les
éléments qui vous paraissent un peu
essentiel à reprendre
d'accord merci merci Monsieur le
président
bon il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de
thèmes
avant de parler des banques centrales
sur un porteur général et puis des tiers
de confiance peut-être la question
de Monsieur caoutchi qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière
bon derrière il y a en fait c'est un peu
un test de Rorschach c'est à dire qu'on
regarde tous la même tâche et puis on a
tous une interprétation différente dans
certains voient une
occasion de s'enrichir facilement
d'autres
le fait de d'échapper
d'échapper au contrôle
d'autres voient la blockchain je pense
que bon ce qu'il y a derrière
financièrement c'est cette innovation
intellectuelle disons qui est la
blockchain qui peut servir ailleurs je
pense que
j'ai déjà discuté avec des
des
gens qui sont intéressés par ce système
là pour transmettre des informations par
exemple dans le domaine sanitaire pour
partager des informations entre des
donneurs de greffe et des receveurs des
choses comme ça ça permet de faire
circuler l'information de manière
décentralisée rapide efficace voilà je
pense que il reste ça derrière et qui
sera utilisé si on ne trouve pas de
défaut mais depuis 15 ans a priori il y
a pas eu de défaut
fondamental dans cette conception il y a
des domaines d'application bon et
effectivement je partage le scepticisme
sur le fait que la monnaie la finance
soit le terrain le plus adapté
est-ce que la finance a besoin de plus
de vitesse aujourd'hui on en est à une
détention moyenne de titres de l'ordre
de la seconde avec le trading haute
fréquence etc donc ce que la finance a
encore besoin de plus de vitesse que des
des ordinateurs qui un petit
fonctionnait à la milliseconde ça c'est
une question est-ce que la finance n'a
pas besoin de régulation ça c'est une
autre grande question donc bon
mais c'est pour ça que j'aime bien
revenir au projet de départ c'est à dire
que le la créature a totalement échappé
à son créateur que comme souvent les
financiers s'emparent d'une nouvelle
technologie qui permet d'augmenter la
rapidité les occasions de gains etc mais
on a vraiment des points faibles et je
pense que pour répondre à plusieurs
questions qui posaient un peu sur ce sur
ce thème là je pense que vraiment le
point faible du système ce sont les
plateformes
FTX en est un exemple quand même quand
on a affaire à on considère qu'il y
avait un million de clients bftx il y
avait pas de comptabilité c'est-à-dire
qu'en été dans le flou le plus total
c'est-à-dire le PDG pendant les réunions
jouer à des jeux vidéo plutôt que
d'écouter ses conseillers etc enfin
c'était donc installer dans un paradis
fiscal sans comptabilité et avec voilà
des déclarations un peu à leur porte
pièces sur et
et la faille de FTX en gros c'est le
doute qu'a fait naître son principal
concurrent qui est baïonnons qui par
quelques tweets à commencer à
déstabiliser l'affaire en disant
finalement je suis pas sûr que ça cette
cette entreprise soit vraiment très
cohérente et ça suffit à faire plonger à
faire plonger FTX en quelques heures
donc on a quand même des des colosses au
pied qui sont très très
fragiles et pour reprendre
cette question alors on a eu des
scandales de ce type là en France
je suis à l'Université de Bourgogne il y
a Dijon il y a eu une entreprise qui
appelait RR crypto qui a soi-disant été
l'objet d'une fraude mais qui avait
quand même quelques milliers de clients
et 50 millions de d'euros ont disparu en
tout cas on ne sait pas où ils sont
localisés donc il y a quand même des des
des
soucis de ce côté là et
je pense que la régulation doit surtout
s'appliquer
aux plateformes puisque
la plupart des crypto sont générés par
des Bitcoin est
surgit du nez en quelque sorte c'est un
algorithme donc il n'est même pas
localisé dans la Silicon vanille ou je
ne sais quoi il n'y a pas d'entreprises
derrière
certaines cryptos sont gérés par des
entreprises qu'on peut investiguer le
Bitcoin c'est un processus quasiment
auto auto reproductible donc je pense
que cette et d'ailleurs l'Europe a mis
l'accent surtout et puis aussi en France
sur les prestataires les prestataires de
services en actif numérique je pense que
c'est vraiment là que que doit s'appuyer
le le contrôle sur ces plateformes et
Ledger qui est
Ledger permet justement aux
consommateurs de gérer eux-mêmes de se
passer des plateformes de conserver les
les fonds chez eux c'est à dire quand
dans l'esprit de la comme auto il n'est
jamais question de plateforme ça a été
c'est le marché en fait qui a créé
ces banques et je pense que le Ledger
permet justement de pour les adeptes en
tout cas de gérer directement eux-mêmes
leur portefeuille ce qui est quand même
un peu plus sûr
alors pour le pour le le nombre
d'emplois qui qui serait concernés en
France en 2021 les échos avaient publié
une étude là-dessus ils estimaient 1000
emplois directs donc on n'a pas un
secteur qui est
qui est vraiment qui est vraiment
dominant
sur les banques centrales plusieurs
questions ont posé là-dessus alors les
banques centrales sont pas bien sur
vigilantes puisque on a on a un attrait
de la nouveauté
etc et donc la proposition de
renumériques et qui est testé d'ailleurs
par la Banque de France
qui a fait des vraiment des avancées
là-dessus repose là-dessus et alors ça
bouge beaucoup on a affaire une
révolution dans ce domaine là j'ai pas
mal travaillé sur l'histoire au 17e 18e
siècle l'apparition des banques des
banques centrales etc on est vraiment
dans ce moment là je pense aujourd'hui
et parce que le souci aussi des
autorités
monétaires et financières c'est aussi
les grands acteurs type Visa MasterCard
etc et la crise la crise ukrainienne a
montré que la maîtrise des des systèmes
de paiement et et vraiment essentiel et
donc une appropriation et le fait que
l'ABCE puisse gérer directement un
neuronumérique qui ne serait pas un
outil spéculatif qui permettrait
d'établir un lien direct dans la sphère
numérique entre les usagers et le bilan
de la banque centrale que le maladie
Christine Lagarde ça serait l'équivalent
d'un billet numérique ça me semble être
quelque chose qui permettrait justement
de réduire le nombre d'adeptes pour ces
montagnes russes
qu'on connaît dans le dans le monde des
des crypto monnaie et la Fed est aussi
assez vigilante et ne fait pas partie
des pays d'ailleurs en première ligne
pour l'adoption d'un dollar numérique
mais je pense que de toute façon c'est à
l'étude dans la plupart des banques
centrales aujourd'hui la Chine et la
Suède étaient les premières dans ce
domaine là mais
j'allais dire aussi pour pour évoquer
peut-être rapidement aussi il y a une
question sur le Salvador la Centrafrique
il faut bien se rendre compte que en
Europe nous ne sommes pas
pour les usagers si c'est 5 ou 10% de la
population ça constitue encore quelque
chose qui permet de comment dire de
dynamiser un portefeuille financier pour
certains adeptes mais on n'est pas dans
un phénomène de protection par rapport à
la crise de la monnaie souveraine on a
d'autres pays
en Afrique
au Moyen-Orient ou la devise officielle
décroche totalement
au Liban par exemple les gens sont
attirés par les crypto de vie parce que
c'est un moyen de protection contre le
chute la chute de la livre et on a
d'autres pays aussi de ce type là donc
il y a aussi ce phénomène de protection
Enfin de protection de tentative de
protection par rapport à l'effondrement
de la monnaie nationale qu'on ne connaît
pas ni aux États-Unis ni en Europe
voilà donc on n'a pas le même non plus
de réduire aux anges et certains pays se
positionnent clairement sur le créneau
paradis fiscal 2.0 ou 3.0 voilà l'idée
c'est voilà vous voulez faire fructifier
votre argent à l'abri du système
bancaire traditionnel venez placer chez
nous en Bitcoin puisque c'est notre
deuxième monnaie légale et vous le ferez
sans sans trop de soucis
ce qui va poser d'ailleurs des problèmes
puisque la République centrafricaine au
niveau énergétique enfin au niveau
électricité est quand même doté de
manière très très
parcimonieuse et ça si vraiment il y a
un gonflement de ce côté là le
l'écosystème du minage va poser de gros
problèmes à la population locale il va
falloir choisir un moment donné entre
faire fonctionner l'éclairage public ou
ou les les fermes de minage et donc
alors les chiffres sont toujours très
très volatiles et dépend de la capacité
de calcul qu'il faut mais on considère
en gros que il faut à peu près 10000
euros en termes de coûts de production
pour le mineur
pour obtenir un Bitcoin c'est à dire que
le Bitcoin ne devient
un placement en termes de minage
avantageux au-delà de la au delà de
10000 dollars il y a pas mal de fermes
de minage au Texas par exemple et donc
si le Bitcoin atteint les 10000 dollars
toutes les fermes de minage ferment bon
il n'y a pas que le Bitcoin et
d'ailleurs il y a d'autres solutions
plus plus intéressantes
qui ne repose pas sur une un système de
preuve de travail avec du minage qui a
une très forte tension électrique mais
des preuves d'enjeux ethereum et passer
un système beaucoup moins énergivore on
considère que
ces 99% moins énergivores depuis qu'ils
sont passés à ce système là et
d'ailleurs pour ce qui est d'une monnaie
de banque centrale ils ne fonctionnera
pas ils ne fonctionnera pas sur une
validation par des acteurs privés mais
bien sûr par une surveillance de la
Banque centrale donc on aura quand même
on n'aura pas ce problème énergétique
mais qui est vraiment qui est vraiment
aussi central on considère que c'est la
consommation électrique du Danemark qui
est nécessaire pour en un an qui est
nécessaire pour contrôler les pour
valider les transactions en Bitcoin
c'est à dire que voilà le Bitcoin
consomme autant qu'un pays
certes enfin tel que le Danemark
aujourd'hui ne serait-ce que pour pour
surveiller par des acteurs privés ce que
font ordinairement les banques ou des
groupes comme visa ou comme MasterCard
alors j'ai dû oublier beaucoup de
questions mais pour ce qui est des
usagers alors encore une fois dans des
pays où la monnaie nationale n'est pas
en danger sur le marché des changes et
ne connaît pas des taux de d'inflation
de sang ou 1000% comme dans certains cas
en Afrique
ou en Amérique centrale les
usagers sont principalement des jeunes
adeptes aussi
de jeux vidéo de jeux numériques etc
parce qu'il y a aussi des passerelles
entre les crypto monnaie les et les
certaines formules de de jeux donc on a
quand même un
noyau de base outre certains
spéculateurs outre certains spéculateurs
de métiers on a quand même à noyau de
base qui est quand même encore assez
restreint mais c'est une population que
auquel les banques centrales s'occupent
puisque encore une fois on
il faut protéger effectivement les
consommateurs alors comment les protéger
parler d'éducation je pense
par la régulation mais là dessus je
pense que pas mal de chantiers sont sont
intégrés
et on est on est
on est face à des acteurs privés il y a
il y a un moteur quand même de toute
cette de toute cette cryptosphère ce qui
est je lisais ça récemment dans un
articles du Monde c'est l'avidité
l'avidité 2.0 elle est à peu près la
même que que dans le film de d'Oliver
Stone Wall Street c'est à dire que voilà
greed is good voilà à partir du moment
où il y a de l'argent à gagner on a des
acteurs qui vont qui vont miser mais
voilà il faut les prévenir
encadrer les détaillants les plateformes
je crois ça c'est vraiment le talon
d'Achille et et
bon je pense que le monde bancaire en
tout cas en France est quand même assez
prudent là-dessus et conseil assez bien
ses clients mais on a on a cette cette
ce monde numérique exerce un attrait
certains pour pour des catégories de la
population
merci professeur d'avoir essayé de
répondre au maximum de questions en tout
cas certaines bien sûr restent encore
un peu latente mais nous allons
poursuivre nos travaux pendant une heure
et demie pour rentrer dans cette
question notamment de la régulation dans
la future table ronde merci Monsieur
professeur merci d'avoir fait le
déplacement et merci encore une fois
pour la qualité de votre présentation
merci monsieur le président